did you ever think you make
it Victory I know this life me yeah why
would you bet on Goliath when we got bet
David valueing giv values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we G no
value to haters how run homie look what
I become I'm I'm the
one Ryan Garcia how you feeling I'm
feeling amazing how you doing I'm doing
good man first thank you for having me
on yeah of course I know you're going to
do your introduction I think it's
important that I tell you I'm grateful I
appreciate this you have a huge platform
I love what you represent I shot you a
message I think while back I said man
you're
everything that I love what people do
with their platform which is speak the
truth and try to work issues out that
people are so scared to try to work out
you know I believe in honest discussion
and uh no hate towards anybody so uh
what you do here is very amazing and I'm
honored to be one of your guests and
you're actually one of the few people I
actually reach out to be on your show
it's always like they reach out to me
but for me um out of respect because of
what you do and and you're a strong role
model big inspiration even for myself
and um I'm just really I'm excited to be
here well what's great to have you on
obviously from my end
uh I've spent weekends watching you yeah
I get people to come together to watch
you fight and you've entertained the
world with your
abilities uh and and as a as a young guy
you know when you and I first started
talking and we had a a gathering also at
the Dom man party in Miami when we did
that Soho House deal and I talked to you
I said listen as a as a young guy coming
up I mean you've been doing this for a
while you've been boxing since you were
78 years old and from there to get to
the top and then you got tens of
millions of people following you you got
the Limelight you got all the attention
you got the money you got the fame you
know you just recently bought yourself a
nice you know Escalade you know armored
truck and the R8 and nice Christmas you
got your family you got your kids you
got a lot of stuff going on I got a lot
on my plate yes you do but also at the
same time you know uh for me everybody
when you're in a situation like this
Ryan everybody can say well you know he
should do this and he should do that and
he should do this and you should do this
and da d d the hardest part about being
uh successful that early that quickly is
forget about the art of fighting that's
one you know forget about learning your
skill set that's one then the other one
is marketing you're able to do that as
well there's plenty of videos of content
creators that are coming in and wanting
to see how fast you are and you know the
stuff that you would do with the Rope I
mean it's insane how those videos go
viral there's so many of them 50 100
million views 20 million views you're
able to get that so you're marketable
and then at the same time you
know it helps that you're a very
handsome good-look guy when I saw you at
the the party I'm like dude you you're a
very marketable guy with that side how
do you do for you and I know this is a
random question to start off with how do
you handle being a celebrity as a young
guy how do you handle that Jesus Christ
tell me more
so as a follower of Christ you died to
yourself you're dying to yourself so I
don't look at myself as the guy you know
even though I know I'm confidently know
who I am as as a man and what God called
me to do and you know um how I how how I
put my feet you know keep my feet down
you know 10 10 10 toes down how do I do
that because I'm dying to my ego every
day ego could kill a man you know pride
comes before the fall so do I move in
Authority because of Christ yes so so
when I speak you're going to listen no
matter what you cannot not listen but
again people choose to deny the truth
and that's okay that's why Jesus says
Those Who Have Eyes let them see and
those who have ears let them hear my job
is to plant the seed if you don't want
it I dust my feet off and go to the next
house somebody's going to feel it so at
the end of the day that's how I stay
humble um I've been following God since
I was a young boy so you know I had
dreams of me fighting in heaven like all
my whole life has been very prophetic
and uh that's keeping me humble and I've
I've tried my best every day to try to
follow that you know again not perfect
I'll raise my hand up right now not the
perfect guy but through Christ he's
going to perfect me and make me more
holy every day because I'm following the
truth so every day you know it's all
about um just the quote in the Bible
goes a righteous man falls seven times
gets up eight the number eight means New
Beginnings mhm so that's even prophetic
in itself that it ends up at eight you
know that even that verse you know so
you know they say they say God speaks to
us through people right I mean I read u
a quote uh by poet hafus and HAF said
that you know God you know uses human
beings as a flute and he speaks through
them right and this was a a poet written
long long ago uh uh in Persian so who
does God use to speak to you and Whisper
to you meaning uh uh while I'm coming up
and I had success early on in my teens
when I got out of the army I fell
obviously not at the levels of the fame
and the money that you've made but I
fell and I fell hard and it was
embarrassing and everybody was looking
at me like hey what happened to you H
you were supposed to be this successful
business guy and millionaire you're not
now you're thinking about going back
into the army you're trying to find a
place to hide and all this stuff and
that's without any cameras cuz nobody
has a clue who I was this is just among
small friends but in in the world of
boxing there is constant feedback
criticism hate all that stuff that's
coming to you so who who do you speak to
that you trust where you say I think
this person I can listen to and trust
that they're giving me the right
feedback I have many people in my life
but I would say the one that popped in
my
mind is my my pastor his name is Pastor
Elias Flores and I could call him up
anytime and he always has sound advice
he's very just technical I call him he's
he's my cuz I have a Nam Derek James and
he's very technical he's out there in
Dallas trains Errol Spence Jr I said
you're you're like the spiritual Derek
James like everything you do is so so
technical like boom he he could hit
points that are super layered and he has
a lot of experience so he's a person I
go to of course my father my father has
a lot of great advice and he's very calm
very peaceful and um speaks gently but
it makes sense you know he's very
strategic but he does it in just a
balance way so those are kind of and
then my coach Derek everybody that's if
you want to give me advice I just let
look it I would say even a 5-year-old
little kid if if they had something that
they were that they were making sense on
right I'm going listen to that I could
find inspiration I agree at anything I
love that Ryan since what age have you
been protected let me explain what I
mean by that um sometimes when you're a
young athlete you will you will have a
lot of people that are around you
because they know they're going to make
a lot of money and they know you're
going to be somebody right if you know
what I'm saying like it's constantly
like hey do this for them do that for
him protect them here protect them here
since what age have you been protected
by guys who have been making sure for
you to not make a mistake I think my
mom's been the one trying to protect me
the most at the end of the day people
are coming into my life to take what I
have not to get help me and protect me
most most of the time when I was first
coming up now I have a solid team but
when I was first coming up you had
people that just seen me as a dollar
sign and and thought they could you know
use their words of mouth to try to lure
them in to you
know doing everything supposedly is
going to be for me but really it's for
them and their benefit and you know I
had to deal with that my mom was a shark
though your mom was a shark shark okay
like that's where I get my sharkness
from mom and dad are still together yes
okay yes so my mom's the shark she's she
hunts everybody now run away you know
what I mean run away cuz she don't play
She where where's she from where's her
family from she she grew up in Los
Angeles she went to us she graduated
from USC and um and you know she was
just born and raised in in La pretty
much my dad so educated somebody that
went to school somebody that you know my
dad Chicago um went to musical school
was a piano pianist and then he also
designed uh little kids clothing dresses
and things like that they were doing
good for a time being till I was about
seven years kind of like when I first
started boxing that's when everything
kind of just went South because of the
the O8 crash and um at that point it was
like okay now we got to move to
Victorville Victorville is a very small
town you know five bedroom five kids one
bedroom little Cita and we're trying to
figure it out you know they're trying to
you know make a right move and oh wait
so you're 9 10 years old yes yes I'm
around there so you're born 88 right
you're an August 98 98 you're 98 but
you're an August baby or August baby
August baby okay so I'm a Leo I wouldn't
be anything else lion you like the lion
yep I agree and I'm very familiar with
Victorville on the way to Vegas it's
right by the freeway there that's what
they all say about it but no it's it's a
it's a city where you know it's I don't
it's just somewhat overlooked I guess
because of you're passing through but um
no I I I had a very strong self-belief
in myself since I was little and a lot
of people knew that you know they would
tell me but I knew it and I knew I was
headed somewhere but yeah so um my my
Dad decided to put all the money into
me it was actually interesting story my
dad go I mean my uncle goes one of um
one of the kids in in our family is
going to be the fight is going to be the
golden your uncle saying that yeah he
said that before like a long long time
ago cuz he used to box and he made it to
the Nationals but then he got married
and like kind of like threw him off the
course of even trying to go
pro so he says to himself when he's over
there at the Nationals he goes somebody
in our family's going to come back here
and somebody's going to win and
somebody's going to take this to a whole
another level all the kids are born boom
boom boom he said when he seen me he's
like that's the one and then also my mom
goes when I was born all the Asian
ladies came in our room and my mom was
like why is all the Asian ladies coming
by you're like cuz he's the lucky big
cuz number eight in um I guess in China
is a very lucky number so my birthday is
898 so like oh this is a lucky is luck
period right right I mean it's a great
number but um and I'm not trying to do
that to toot my own horn but it's more
on the the sense of like I I've had a
lot of
significant I would say would you say
signs okay signs that point to like I'm
destined for something that could be
great so you've been protected so okay
your family loved you know Uncle says
this one's the one he's going to do
something the Asian ladies come in 888
8898 something's going to happen my son
born 1223 23 my mom born
4464 you understand like numbers have
like spiritual meanings to I'm a numbers
guy so you're you're speaking my
language
so how many how many uh fist fights did
you get into before you graduated high
school my whole fist fights my whole
thing is I never socked nobody in the
face when I stru when I when I was in a
street fight I would just slap them so
this big kid first one I think one of my
first fights and mind you I'm always
scared to fight in the street I used to
be terrified like I was when I was a kid
I could fight in the ring but on the
street I would I would curl up into a
ball cuz I like I don't know what this
is like I it's not you know it's not
coordinated I'm used to coordination and
and protocol and you know structure
structure uh and there's no structure in
the street fight but anyways you push me
to that point then then something else
happens then then I tell you to run cuz
then I'm I'm I'm coming in a whole
different manner like they see it in my
eyes so anyways this kid pushed me in
basketball it's like maybe oh was the
fourth grade big kid huge but I told him
I was like stop pushing me man like it's
not gonna like okay anyways he threw a
punch I just hit him to the body knocked
him out that got in trouble whatever but
I would never hit him in the face so
then this other kid named Debo Debo out
of all the
names
Debo Debo like crazy Debo right no but
he wasn't like Debo as in that big Debo
he was just like an he he boxed with my
Dad I'm like dude you know what I could
do what are you doing he throws my
basketball down he was mad about
basketball it's a basketball again
that's the thing nobody knows when you
play street ball there's going to be a
fight yeah I've got in three fights and
I'll share another one so anyways he got
it really bad so he threw my ball down
the street and then I'm like okay I'm
going to let you do that I grab his ball
and I throw it across the fence I said
you go get your ball I'll go get my ball
we thought he said nope we need it now I
said Deo you know what I could do he
goes this is a street fight it's
different I said okay let's go he tries
to kick me I'm like block like what are
you
do I hit him so hard so many slaps I'm
Debo stop you're crying up I don't want
to hit you you anymore he keeps swinging
shoot I'm breaking the mic now um I hit
him so hard he had a wel in my hand all
over his face like you could how old are
you at the S how old is he I'm 14 around
14 so now we're a little old so 14 you
can really hurt you can feel hurting
somebody at 14 I slapped him so bad I'm
sorry Debo if you're hearing this Debo I
slapped him so hard I'm like dang Debo
he goes back home crying I'm like I feel
bad I always feel bad whenever I beat
somebody up I'm like dang about to do
that but then I'm like you know he asked
for it so you know anyways his mom comes
pulling up I'm like dang I'm in trouble
for real Daddy's going to come
everybody's going to come try to jump me
or something she goes thank you for
beating my son's ass he deserved that he
needed that ass wow I said oh no problem
Miss I forgot her name um and then my
friend I had a lot of things man my
friend that he became my best friend he
was like 6'2 he's a professional boxer
now his name's Lawrence King we were in
um we were in PE I believe um
I didn't know him at this time but he
heard out I was a boxer he said you box
he's like you don't box I said yes I do
box he said look at you you don't he's
basically like you don't look like no
boxer just shut up you ain't no boxer I
said come to my house we could put some
gloves on and then you gonna find out
that I'm a fighter
anyways nobody has ever there he is yeah
hey what's up Lord um nobody um he
sparred Canelo he's sparring everybody
now
anyways I hope la don't mind this but he
was a troubled kid back then you know he
was out there doing stupid stuff and I
was the kind of kid around it but I was
like this ain't it like let's not do
this this is not the move like got let's
not mess with that like just just let's
just focus I was that kid like I I got
you guys I understand this life like I I
want to I want to make some money too
but I don't want to make it that way you
know anyway so I told him I said come to
my house nobody really would come to my
house when I would tell him that if they
said they want to fight us so come to my
house come find out we'll put some
gloves on so you don't get hurt anyway
he's the only one that comes on a bik of
course the dude is huge of course he
wants to challenge this little I at time
maybe like 56 55 at 11 19 you know does
the does the high school know you're a
fighter do they know you they know I'm a
fighter they didn't really make a big
noise about it but are you a tough guy
or you hanging out with
gang I look like I look like the guy
just like yo that's like I mean I don't
know if this is offensive but like the
gay friend you know what I mean like
just hanging out with all the girls at
the end of the day I wasn't I was just
vibing with all them I just was like
feminine energy I just sometimes I need
it you know what I mean so for you you
were good with the girls that's crazy to
say I was great with the girls what do
you mean early off yeah of course
because I just treat them like my main
objective is not to just like if you
come in with the sense of like I want to
just [__] you they feel that energy you
know what I mean excuse my language you
come in like that I just want [__]
guess what she going to feel that and be
like this dude's a
weirdo at the end of the day I just want
to be authentic I don't like bad energy
so if the girl got bad energy I'm outfit
I don't care how what you look like you
look like something crazy your energy is
horrible get away from me please anyways
so I was good with lady so he probably
thought it was weak or something he
comes to the house we fight for like two
hours straight mind you I would have
knocked him out if he was my size two
hours straight two hours straight like
you boxing gloves okay got it it's 2
hours straight he's bleeding I'm
bleeding I'm like bro can we stop like
he want I said I'm not quitting so he's
like you cool I was like we made an
agreement I was like we're cool okay
anyways we end up taking a picture
posting on Facebook he has little
something in his mouth I had my mouth
I'm like okay we had a good fight
anyways he comes back again and I
thought he was talented although he was
way bigger than me I was like no he has
something still though like some guys
really even how big they are they can't
fight he could fight he and me some good
shots but I also cracked him and then I
said come back again cuz I had a
different strategy this time he comes
back he want to admit this I could call
him up right now actually I call Floyd
too right now anyways what I going to
say is I hit him so hard to the
body cuz he was taking all my head shots
I was like okay I got to go to this
man's body now like this is my objective
this next time around he it would it
didn't even last 30 minutes right it
lasts way less than that he goes I hate
Hot Cheetos Hot Cheetos like it's not
hot Cheetos you can't take body shots
kid you better have been working on that
core right now cuz your other opponent
is going to be listening to this
Lawrence I got to go watch him fight
though he just invited me but yeah that
was a little story of those little
fights here and there so three fights
fourth grade more there's more okay got
it but no no like you're not the kid
that grew up with gangs guns you know
craziness you you stayed away from okay
so you were more the guy who knew how to
fight but you're more at the gym you're
with the girl RS that's you in high
school is that a pretty good assessment
or would you say you played some high
school ball did you play sports or I
tried to play basketball but my teachers
would complain to my coach that I'm
talking too much in class and he would
never let me play I'm I was really good
he recruited me he I was playing in PE
and I I was killing these dudes running
Point like I'm like like like I'm
running point like I do now you know and
he was like man you play like this kid
bo bo boom he's giving me these
accolades of some other kid that he won
the state and he's like you remind him
of it and I was
like I was like okay I want to play like
let's do it anyways he never gave me my
shot I would have killed it if I would
have stepped on that Court basketball
I'm still good I'm still good
interesting okay so so so then you come
out you have your first fight uh uh I
want to say June of uh uh uh I don't
know what year it is June of year the
fight in Tijana June of 2016 June 19
2016 at 17 years old you turned Pro I me
Pro cuz my my my my family needed money
money and they changed the age
requirements to go to the Olympics from
I believe it was 17 to 19 so now I can't
go to the
Olympics I'm like what am I here for I
just want I just made the Olympic team I
made the the I would say now would be
under 19 Squad to be like you know the
US Travel team I was like what am I
doing I got to go pro you know this is
going to be a waste of time for me and
my parents needed money we all needed
money so I was like let's just do it how
much you got paid your first fight
nothing
so nothing first fight then Golden Boy
comes and assigns you in November a
couple months later yeah cuz I went end
winning like four fights in Mexico um I
had a manager and he gave me $50,000
bonus so I would say I started off with
50,000 yeah I mean that's that's real
money if you don't have money at first
when getting started I I spent it within
two months what you spend it on Gucci
whatever I
wanted okay so so so so you make you get
the 50k shout out GUI you get a couple
things
just kid and then you're with golden boy
was what was your first time you met
Oscar was that the first time you met
him or you met him before turning
pro Oscar hit me up on
Instagram osar hit you up on so he was
prospecting through Instagram respect to
him for prospecting that way I guess so
so he hit you up on Instagram and then
what happens you oh man this is awesome
like this is cool but I didn't really
trip on it I just thought like that's
somebody I up to I resonate with Oscar
we you know we have a lot of similar
qualities you know his he's
Mexican-American I'm Mexican ameran he
was has a great left hook I have a great
left hook um and you know that really
resonated with me so I was like okay I
could relate to him you know did you
look up to him as a kid coming up in
high school just like anybody you know
you're a fighter you love people that
bring that type of energy you know I
always love when you would get with your
family and put on fight on and it was
like an event you know it was like a
party and he would bring that and so
with Floyd so those were the two people
I looked up to the most as in like I
want to bring boxing that whatever that
is that's what I want to do so did I
look up to him um in a way yes Floyd
also tried to sign me so now I got two
people that look up to me want to sign
same time yes so how did Floyd reach out
to you one is Instagram DM I forgot it
was through some other people and then
we were chilling for a little bit and
then he told me to spar gym I sparred in
front of him but you know what Floyd me
and Floyd it was different because Floyd
is more harder to
impress so I didn't like that Vibe I
felt like he didn't believe in me I like
I don't like people that don't believe
in me like I'm okay I'll just go with
these guys that's why I made that
decision to not sign with Floyd or top
rank so when so when you got the call uh
or the DM from uh uh from Oscar yeah how
much longer did you sign with him like
was it a quit thing quick thing we it's
like okay great let's make it work no it
was like let's figure it out you know
let Roger do his thing Roger at the time
was my
manager and I kind of just let him do
his thing we signed I was excited and
got a fight at the Forum my first fight
knocked the guy out so it started off
good it started off good when did you
start making real money one where you
were like okay now I'm getting a taste
of real good money I think when I got
this deal from Jim shark you know they
had given me like a lot of money you
know every month I don't remember how
much it was at least 250,000 per month
no not per month that's crazy the what
they gave you yeah they gave me yeah but
that would get paid every month got it
and and this is I don't know if those
are the exact numbers I don't want to
say something El you're a teen at this
time when when they give you that money
or you like 16 17 okay 19 years old got
it so when is the first time you made
money off a fight uh actually it wasn't
off a fight it was off a deal that I did
with Oscar because if you remember I was
going to fight this guy named Avery
sparrow and of course this happens in my
life this guy ends up going to
jail the day of the
weigh-ins of course this happens to
me I'm like this is
unbelievable golden boy tries to save
the show M cuz everybody bought the
tickets for me so they Tred to save the
show by throwing some dude named Romero
duno on me on last minute I said I
didn't prepare for this guy why would I
fight him right now you crazy not doing
that oh and then they put out a story
that I'm scared
Golden Boy my own promotion company says
I'm scared put on that fight it only
lasts about a minute 30 um and he
goes I'm scared blah blah blah I'm like
I'm scared what this guy going to jail
then you want Golden Boy put the yeah
yeah and I said I'm not saving the show
for nobody at that point they knew I was
different I said I'm not fighting him
you guys are
crazy and then guess what I I work out
one of the biggest deals that Golden Boy
has done signing a prospect then they
had to pay me like $8 million in bonuses
and they threw me in you the first bonus
was 1.5 million
so at I forgot how old I was maybe in my
early 20s then boom I make I'm already
in the I'm in the millions so once I
seen a million in my bank account I was
said that's crazy huh dad I was like
cool forgot about it after like what it
do to you what it do to you when you
when you got the money did it I don't
know what it did to me all I know is I
had it cuz don't value money like that I
give away money all the time I just
don't tell people like I don't write
stories about it I give money to random
people if I feel God is telling me to if
God telling me right now and I felt in
my spirit give Pat this your watch right
now I would take off my watch on this
live podcast say you have my watch
now and I love that I I love that watch
I watch it's schol it's a nice looking
watch and if you love it you're GNA have
it but guess what at the end of the day
that's how I moveed so I I was never
scared of money so money came to me yeah
money keeps coming to me but it's not my
money it's really God's money so I don't
care this doesn't matter to me at the
end of the day I like to look good I
love to look good and that's what you
know I try I try to look at my like look
the best I could possibly look but it's
not it's has nothing to do with other
than me trying to be you know the best
version of myself like I like the dress
clean do you do you love boxing I love
boxing you love boxing I love boxing
okay so what's your vision with boxing
what do you want to do with boxing I'm
just going to just like David right when
David um in the Bible he grew his
popularity through his battles that's
how he was before he was king that's why
Saul started hating on him I'm just
growing my platform through boxing
that's it do you have a vision like
meaning do you oh I have a vision I have
a big Vision what what's your vision
specific with boxing I'm just going to
be the best fighter in the world and
then I'm going to SAR everybody and they
won't even expect it that's my vision
I'mma beat the people that they don't
I'm getting everything back in blood I I
did this fight with javante specifically
for a reason you know it was more of a
sacrifice to help save boxing because
nobody the boxing was boring it was
nobody was talking about it it was it
was losing to these gimmick fights that
were making more noise than the real
fights I was like I always knew that me
and javante were going to be a huge
fight
anyways I'm in a horrible place before
after after the like before the javant
I'm in a horrible Place tell spiritually
just in my relationship and just all
that I'm doing in my life like I'm going
haywire but I can't pull out cuz they
already they're they're going to say the
worst of me but I said okay let me pick
my big boy big boy boots on and let's
get to it I told myself against
everything everybody told me MH don't do
it don't take the
rehydration all the things that he put
on me right I don't want to get too much
into it cuz every body should know what
what went down but in case they don't
I'll explain a little bit anyways so
javante and me I was looking for a fight
I just had beat Javier Fortuna and at
that place I at that point I was in a
good place and I was ready to fight him
I said let's run it in October it was in
July I F Javier said let's run in
October they played with me they said
it'll be October then they said up we're
going to do December I said okay let's
do December I'm ready you I can't be on
a break too long cuz I like to move like
I I got to I got to be doing something
anyways they can't do December cuz his
birthday he likes to celebrate his
birthday like what is the [__] what okay
January comes I said let's do it in
January he goes well now I need a tuneup
oh you [__] [__] you need a
tuneup yeah you should probably get a
tuneup too [__] you I'm not doing
nothing to risk this fight I'm going to
give the fans what I told him to do that
I was going to do that's what I'm going
to do I'm going to be I'm going to bring
bring authenticity back to the sport you
guys are playing [__] game in
business nobody would do business with
you if you act like this but it happens
a lot in boxing though right oh to be
boxing yeah is Floyd was telling them
all these
things Floyd's giving this Council to
who do you think is telling him to do
the rehydration Clauses and and not you
know putting all these stipulations on
me you can't you can't do this you can't
do that the ring needs to be this size
it's you know it's it's it's Davis
Garcia it's not but all these things
were all by Floyd Floyd is telling him
what to do how smart is Floyd Floyd is
wise is a wise man and very
strategic you've been you've been uh
you've been spending a lot of time with
Floyd lately right I mean they saw you
running with Floyd and all this stuff
and and I got inite information about
the whole thing what's down how did
javante know that my rib got separated
while I was in the fight how or or or
before the
fight who do you how do you think they
got the information you got to
pay what who do you think told me that
they
paid so I know how much it takes how
much money it takes to betray Ryan
Garcia I know a little Glimpse it
probably could be less for some
people so someone on the outside
leaked that your ribs got my rib got
separated because I was losing so much
weight and this dude
that this dude does a video right the
one that did this to me and goes Ryan
are you okay like it was a random ass
video Ryan are you okay became like a
meme almost like I'm sorry I hurt your
rib I caused you to lose javante I was
like what is he talking about cuz he
made it seem like he really did it like
that and then I I've been beating his
ass the whole training camp I'm cutting
weight I'm dying literally dying like
I'm talking about like there's health
issues to cut that much weight like I'm
I'm dehydrated every day like it's it's
getting bad and then I go
Spar and within the first 30 seconds I
take a routine body shot like a body
shot I could take any day of the week
you know I've gotten hit by way big huge
punchers I just barely boom I move boom
hits me in a spot boom it goes down I
said stop something happened to my rib I
can't breathe I got to stop sparring
nothing crazy like he's beating my ass
and then gets to my rib no it was just a
routine shot hey it's sparring I'm not
going to continue my rib is something's
wrong with my rib I go to the hospital
he's like your rib separated doctor goes
it went lower you know um and it it it
go back up on its own but you need a
rest it for three weeks I don't have
three
weeks I'm running like this I'm running
five miles like this every step holding
my and at the time nobody really seen it
it was just like he got it he got it cuz
they're thinking about the big check not
Ryan you should probably rethink this a
little bit and maybe not
fight so who leaked it to him the guy
who ever was there's only three people
in that in and I'm not even going to
give names cuz I don't want to get sued
but there's only three people that were
in I'm sorry four people that were in
there are these four people that we
would
know I don't know I'm not going to say
nothing so so but Floyd or somebody on
that side told you that they whispered
to them that your ribs were separated
yes that's why javante
n huh I got Judas I got Judas
interesting
somebody came and kissed me on the cheek
and says hey that's the one right like
yo that's crazy it's a crazy move how's
your relationship with Oscar today I
mean obviously we've seen it but how's
it way better it is way better really
yeah what happened what
changed I said I don't do this I don't
do this let's figure it out that's all
it took I don't do this whatever this
chaos is and back I don't do that we're
going to come together we're going to
figure this is out I said I love you I
said regardless of all the media [__] or
legal things I love you let's figure it
out how recent is this I on my phone
somewhere in my phone not not too long
ago so this is recent where you guys had
that conversation M got it okay and so
now uh uh there's if you want to pull up
the Tweet there's a tweet that came out
uh this one right here where Oscar says
pre-run with Floyd Ryan was Haney
post-run with Floyd Ryan Wass rley
Golden Boy has worked with Ryan Garcia
since he turned Pro and together this is
my problem with Oscar stop going to the
media in bashing Floyd there's no reason
I've made him the biggest strong box and
we will make it with relly into a huge
event like we always with Floyd if you
want to give Ryan the secret to defense
in the ring that's great other than that
if you're still a promoter uh like it
says your F off
so is
this did you guys address this together
when you're talking with Oscar no he
just did that cuz he was
mad um at the end of the day Floyd's
influential it's a normal conversation
you have with people so why why don't
you try to go get about you know and
then fight Haney for a bigger
unification so it makes more sense and
you bring bigger just more at
stake I was like I don't know Floyd like
I give the people my word and and
Floyd's like well things change you know
and he gave me like little I'm not going
to I'm going just keep it short and
simple and I was like all right Floyd
like I look up to Flo a lot and I really
do love him and that's why I went out of
the limb to like defend him on online
when I didn't really have to you know
cuz I generally know he has a big heart
Floyd huge heart authentic huge heart
does he like money yes but he also loves
blessing people and he and and he tries
his best so me and Floyd have gotten
close and and I really value that
relationship he actually just called me
I he just FaceTime me right now
I can FaceTime him right now my phone's
not even on I would have FaceTime him on
this podcast can we find me a charger
let me get your charger here yeah I'll
FaceTime him right now here you go we'll
have Floyd Mayweather on this podcast
real
quick what's the biggest difference
between the two ask him what's the
biggest difference between the two
between him and Oscar since you're
spending time with them like you know in
the corner Oscar is getting to the point
where he's being his truest self you
know goofy crazy and whatever he wants
to be and just kind of trying to be
living in truth Floyd's always been
living the truth he's real as it comes
you know that's the difference I would
say strategically are they both
strategic same levels there's a
different level of
strategy I don't know I don't want to
offend anybody got it and and and and
when you when you the reason why I asked
the question is because you're sitting
there you're saying you know Floyd is
giving Council to javante on what the
size of you know the race should be you
know these Clauses you got to put in and
hydration and all this other stuff you
know in the business world this is kind
of like when you sell the business and
you get the right counsel somebody will
say hey be careful with the length of
non-compete okay and how long do you
want to keep you around as CEO uh what's
the amount of stocks you're taking are
you taking stock or cash up front you
take stock that company drops you're not
going to make a lot of money it's too
risky make sure you have a lot of cash
up front and you only leave a little bit
there's all these things that come is
that the relationship that you with
Oscar where Oscar is negotiating for you
and telling you what things to be
looking out for or is that kind of like
the role Floyd is playing it's more like
Floyd that sounds like Floyd got it
Oscar is more of like
[Music]
a he's strategic but in his own
way you know what I mean I can't really
I'm not going to go too deep in it
because I like I told you it's just two
different type of strategies one's like
in your face and one of them's like
moving in silence and just destroying
destroying everything from an from the
top so so you you're going to Floyd
Works in
Shadows Floyd Works in Shadows yeah he's
from be he's in behind the scenes got it
more than you think got it in this
boxing game got it and I'm hopeing I'm
not giving too much information recently
OS Oscar said something about hey Floyd
can do whatever he wants to do but you
got to be careful with poaching what
what what is the poaching how is
poaching treated and boxing like he's
trying like he's trying to act as my
promoter but Floyd is not it's called
being friends with somebody like you
could literally be friends with somebody
you know that right like you could give
me counsel about a fight and if I say yo
Patrick B David was like yo don't fight
that guy right now fight this guy like
what are you doing that's called friends
but I would see like okay if I can be
direct with you because for me I look at
you as a guy that uh uh I'm excited to
see what you're going to do next 10
years like you're going to entertain the
world for 10 years realistically and we
we'd like to see you freaking kill it
the next the day I die totally but but I
mean is specifically with this space
right in in every phase of your life is
a certain space you're trying to conquer
the current space you're in is boxing
right
so do you think for Oscar like from your
standpoint do you think a part of it is
if you were to make a list of who
probably would be Oscar's biggest enemy
I don't know if there's a bigger enemy
for Oscar than Floyd it's so funny they
have a rivalry that goes decades exactly
that's what I'm saying so I mean you
know even the fight between the two them
and what it was like and how Oscar
fought and you know who's who and you
know Oscar had a lot of
potential I think Oscar just didn't
reach his fullest potential why do you
think he let all the [__] get to
him this [__] is [__] all the fame
all the money the girls all that is
[__] there's only one purpose and
that's God whatever God's will is no
that's the truth I don't even think
there's no side because at the end of
the day if you don't fulfill the will of
God what are you doing think about it
what are you doing you're living for
yourself you're just that's why you
that's why you end up messing up cuz you
only living for
yourself so if you're out here doing all
these crazy things of course you're not
going to do what you were supposed to do
he could have been probably the biggest
figh of all time the way his he he
almost did beat Floyd even though he bit
all those closes on Floyd and that's
where Floyd learned it from wow so Floyd
learned a Clauses from Oscar yes and
then he took the torch and took it to a
whole another
level think about it watch the fight
Floyd had the biggest gloves on in the
world go go to a picture of them
fighting look at his gloves and look at
Oscar's gloves I'm G show you how this
game
is if you put the fight between two of
them see if you can find them look at
gloves bro he got heavyweight gloves on
so he got he got Floyd to get
heavyweight gloves how so he he
negotiated Floyd having bigger gloves
than him yes yes yes is that proven is
that like
documented wait hold
up I'm asking Florida if I could call
[Laughter]
him it was a great fight though yeah
Oscar almost got that yeah Oscar did
almost get that but Oscar did what Oscar
do he cannot finish the
job all his biggest fights he lost why
because you cut Corners that's why you
couldn't get over the hill you only get
over the hill when you do things that
that magnify your chances preparation is
key he he must have been cutting Corners
because he could have won all those
fights sham Mo Lee Tito
Trinidad OS Floyd may he had a chance to
win all those fights but but didn't you
need to ask that question
why cuz we out there making mistakes you
know how much so so so I called a few
guys I'm an LA kid right I grew up in LA
and I grew up uh my best friends from
Victor and by the way I want to say I
love you Oscar it's not about that I'm
just trying to tell the truth but but
here's where I'm going with this when I
when I call my friends in La I mean
listen we we grew up watching
uh Tito fighting Vargas and we would
have the best Gada watching the fights
and Cinco de Mayo was like a legendary
weekend everybody would be caught up in
the boxing all that stuff right how much
how much you think you're are you do you
think you're following more Oscar's
footsteps do you think you're follow
more Mayweather's lineage of decisions
being made or Canelo what what do you
think or do you think it's I'm following
Ryan Garcia's way and tell me that tell
me tell me more about trying to be as
truthful as I can and as as authentic as
I can and not trying to do the [__]
that everybody's trying to do cuz I
don't give a [__] about money I give a I
I care about my word excuse my language
so when I get my word I do try my best
to keep my word so when I told the
fans Ry or Haney there was a poll on
Twitter Haney won barely but he
won at the end of the day that was my
first
instinct to give them what that what
what what what what they wanted and you
can pull it up right
here check this out which one is this
it's
coming it's coming it's coming it's
coming when did I share E's elbow are
those oh see look
it who should you fight first I'll let
the people decide in three days so April
20th is a fight right so so obviously I
take Floyd's Council in a way yeah I
mess up people would bash me for it okay
I'll take the
heat that falls out relly uses my name I
don't even like saying his name I'm G
call him Roy oie poly schoy you know
what I mean I don't like saying his name
CU he he's been using my name to build
himself up since we were sparring back
in
2016 you understand this man is famous
for sparring
me and then continues to do it and then
says we're going to fight and because
I'm ready to beat his ass at this point
let me just go get rid of this weirdo
right look at this
weirdo that's a
weirdo why are you doing this just put a
[__] shirt
on great you have abs we all do well at
least some of us
hello weirdo okay he's just a very
obnoxious kid and other day I was ready
to just end it right because I'm getting
ready for a fight when I Spar this guy
right he's super big at this point he
way bigger than
me I'll give it to him he has punching
power I know this my bad let me just
wipe this off I know
this so the first time we spark I'm
moving around the ring let's take his
power away b boom again mind you I'm
still young I'm I'm still learning in my
craft but anyways and he still learned
his craft he he he started boxing late
whatever it's a fight at the end of the
day I know what I have to do I start bo
bo boom moving around boom boom he's
like he me up like you were running the
whole time I said say less I'll see you
tomorrow I go Spar him I said I stand
right there I'm beating his ass the
whole time he caught me with a shot made
it look really worse than it was I grab
him boom boom boom we're fighting boom
boom boom it's a sparring match who
cares anyways he makes a whole edit
about it says I beat his ass he sucks b
boom he gets famous off it I start
beefing with him I'm like you're a [__]
for real this is when this is how long
ago this is like we were young can can
you pull it up we were young young just
SP Ryan Garcia and Roy
Spar when is that it might not be
accurate
though who wins old sparing video see no
see no that's not that's one they they
posted but he at least he put old
sparing
video where is it really at though look
for the oldest
one how many years is that
Rob this one right here is 6 years ago
okay is that the one yes six years ago
anyways we all could we all could make a
edit video of of making it look worse
than it is right you go watch a little
bit it's fine obviously look how young I
look and look how small I'm getting
ready for a fight so you're 19 how old
is he like 21 maybe so you guys are two
years apart I don't know he might be a
little older than that can somebody
check how old R is I'll do it Rob you
keep you keep playing it I'll check it
here yeah anyways it was a whatever
sparm it's like I was [__] cracking
him and and then he started coming on
late but this dude we know he don't have
a chin so if I would have caught him
early he would have been out early you
know like I caught him many times early
he caught me later on where's a spar at
he has 14 outz gloves anyways I don't
want to explain myself cuz this is very
look at I cracked him with that love
boom blocking all his shots nothing's
happening he gets me later on and look
at this look at that he's throwing me on
the floor this thing would never happen
in a real fight at day he's been using
this sparring footage for years who's in
there right now like who who's who are
some names that are in there right now I
don't know who's in there at this point
I really don't and where is this where
is this this is Mayweather gym okay this
is that's why look oh my gosh I cracked
him with that and he tried to come back
anyways he look at this he he can't mess
with me he sucks you know and at the end
of the day he's a sparring Champion he's
four years old that's enough we don't
got to look at anymore you're 19 he's 23
yes okay and I'm getting ready for fight
so I'm cutting weight got it I'm low
he's high I don't really care I'm just
saying let's run it he makes a big deal
about it dude so annoying like okay
whatever so then he uses my name for
fame cut back to this time I say let's
fight we get on negotiations then I
think to myself I could also fight crew
I just want to keep my options open mhm
all of a sudden I'm fighting I was like
okay let's talk to Cruz let's talk to
Ries we even talk to Haney whatever
whoever wants it everyone took offense
to that oh you you going behind my back
no I said it loudly in front of
everybody I kept it transparent yes I
want to fight you Ries I could run it
with
Devin and I could run it with
Cruz anyways he obviously took offense
to that and then they all decided to use
my name and then we they tell me that
the deal is going to be done that's why
I post the thing and then all of a
sudden the next day he announces he's
fighting
Crews I'm like you [__] so I
just post that me pitpull he's fighting
uh yeah yeah
so I post because everybody gives me the
go that this is really happening yeah
then I post it and then I again are seen
as the liar and I'm like dang I see the
tricks I see the tricks it's okay my
mistake is I should have always kept my
word
if I told the people I'm fighting dein
Haney I should have not let nobody
influence me otherwise not neither Floyd
not neither nobody if I say something I
need to keep to it that's the lesson I
learned so that will never happen again
so is is so originally you said even
earlier so Oscar's like hey fight relly
first and from there let's go make a
bigger fight with Haney right Ry is now
15 and one uh uh uh and Haney is 31 and
DB 15 and dumb yeah so so I'm assuming
Floyd's telling you why do you need to
even run Ry why don't you go directly to
Devon I'm assuming that's what Floyd's
giving you or no that's not the feedback
he's giving you no it's your decision
you want to fight Devon yes got it okay
and I'm not changing my mind no more so
is that uh uh are you kind of whispering
to us that that's kind of what's
probably going to be announced 420 420
that's going to be a big fight shusa
yeah that's going to be good I'm K it's
going to I know what I
know need Mike Tyson on this [__] yeah
Snoop Dog Mike me that would be have you
done a Mike Tyson podcast before he's
very I love Mike Mike Mike before my
last fight visited me in my hotel room
he said I just want to hang out
I okay he like I'm in the area I'm like
okay we hang out I'm telling you he want
to leave the room I love him I I gotta
weigh in tomorrow mik like I have to go
to sleep we're talking for hours and
hours and hours laughing I'm like Mike
is in this is pre- weighing yes and I'm
dying bro I'm dying I'm cutting wait
that's me and Mike right there I'm like
Mike that was that day look skinny look
oh my God go go Zoom that doesn't even
look healthy Rob zoom in a little bit on
that go to the next picture holy [__]
what do you weigh what are you weighing
that picture like
144 wow I'm like Mike can you I had to
be like Mike I'm going to sleep
and Michael was like all
right
anyways nobody knows this but I'm going
share it I think one of Mike's team got
me sick so after that day I'm sick like
I got Co or something I'm shivering I'm
like oh my God how I'm going to make
weight I got to start I'm Downing
DayQuil water crazy it doesn't go away I
get enough to lose the weight and then
I'm like how am I'm I going to fight
with this this is crazy I said God what
do I do I call my my strength and
conditioning coach sip I said sip what
do I do I'm sick he goes do you remember
Michael Jordan's Flu Game I said I do
remember that 10 3.9 he was
like lock in like that I said say less
so I started looking up how to perform
under the weather that was my Google
search how to perform under the weather
it mentioned coffee it mentioned this it
mentioned that I said okay what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna drink a bunch of
water so I Dr I drank like seven water
bottles so I'm pissing out everything
then I'm doing the DayQuil and every 3
hours I'm boom boom boom then I'm
training so now I'm trying to sweat it
out so I'm sweating it out I'm doing the
DayQuil I'm doing the water I'm doing
the coffee I'm doing everything I think
I need to do and I don't do it until I
start feeling good enough I get to a
point where I'm like I'm good enough to
fight the first round comes in I'm
fighting this guy dorte I swear my
throat felt like it was closing up I was
like damn whatever I'm in it now it's
already here there's no going back so I
just lock in God thank you for the
strength and I end up knocking him out
yeah I think round eight round eight
come on round eight it's your round out
number eight New Beginnings baby how's
your relationship with
Canelo I asked him to play golf he
didn't hit me
back I don't know why so did you see
Canelo on The Breakfast
Club what do you thought somebody said
well first D I'm a mucho S I miss you
hit me back um second of
all there's no good people it says in
the Bible nobody's good only God so at
the end of the day it's only
good-hearted people and just guys that
got messed up heart and that are lost
that's it you
know um I don't judge nobody because it
says in the Bible um if you judge you
will also be judged by the measuring
stick that you judge on So I keep my
judging
stick very small unless I see some
really funny business then I'm like no
that ain't it but um
I don't want to get involved in their
business but at the end of the
day so will did give me advice and says
don't do it I I I'm like him I'm loyal
you know if we could work it out we
could work it out I I understand family
fights I've been through the worst
family fights you could think of and the
people that oh you'll never forgive them
no you can forgive them I don't believe
in that you know a lot of people hold
grudges I don't believe in grudges I
just keep it moving you know so so is it
is it longterm uh uh if somebody is
going to Las Vegas right now okay and
they got another guy that can make a bet
for a million dollars saying hey five
years from now Ryan's still going to be
with Golden Boy promotion is that a good
bet what did they say in court I plead
the
fit something like
that oh my God
but but but so
you oh [__] this getting crazy out
here oh man by the way gosh you got my
back Hur is is your is your relationship
with Canelo you're good was Canelo some
of course was canel good as a mentor to
you was he like an older brother giving
you feedback was that the kind of
relationship you guys had he was a man
of very few words but when he spoke it
made
sense got it he like to be very reserved
and he like things run away run a
certain way is he super serious most of
the time super serious yeah it's
annoying got it and and is he super
serious because he is maniacal and
obsessed about being the best in his
space I don't know yeah he's like yeah
something like that but for me I I don't
work like that I like to have fun I like
family you know I like Good Vibes you
know it's time to be serious it's time
not to be serious you know and I like to
I brought the energy to the gym when I
come in the gym everybody's having a
great time and we're all working hard
I'm like a brother I'm Brotherhood
Brotherhood can't be like you think
you're the [__] I think I'm the [__] I
don't work that way are you coachable
are you a guy that's coachable I'm only
coachable to the people that make sense
so I'm not going to listen to somebody
that don't make sense my coach Derek
James makes sense I respect him I humble
myself I don't usually I speak and then
I think like I know something and I
think this is the better move but with
him I understand that he just he's very
sharp and he makes sense and he's moving
in authent authenticity and truth so I'm
going to relate to that and I'm going to
say okay this guy is speaking the truth
I have to listen to this because it says
in the Bible seek wise counsel not seek
dumb
counsel which one are you going to do
you going to listen to the dumb counsel
or the wise counsel cuz at the end of
the day you seek wise counsel so if it's
not wise why would I listen to you if
you never did what I was able to do why
am I listening to you right now so he
was a great coach though D James Dereck
James he told you don't do the shoulder
shoulder roll you're not Mayweather he's
he like that but at the end of the day
me and that's the one thing we laugh
about cuz I show him the sh and he
starts laughing it's not bad but it's
not great yet but I'm have Floyd trained
me on doing it he told me he was going
to train me on how to do the shoulder
room have you have you sparred with
Mayweather at all or no no we wanted to
do it but I didn't that should be an
interesting spot but then we also said
that um that' be crazy
though anyways Floyd told me he's like
I'm going to do he's I have you have my
word I'm I'm going to teach you it more
and then I said or we're going to do the
video at the end of the day he told me
that my shoulder rooll was good Floyd
told you that he was like I don't see no
problem with it that's the people
talking because they never seen a
Mexican do the shoulder roll you see a
Mexican dude is like I don't even look
right I don't
care I'm doing it so you think you got
to be a Mexican to do it you think you
got to be to do shoulder what it is
yeah but the shoulder is a beautiful
thing and and Mayweather is so super
good at it and James Tony that's James
Tony correct y yep y lights out shout
out lights out hey Ryan any any for you
any desire like in your mind uh maybe I
I'll ask this question a different way
uh basketball do you follow
basketball I follow everything okay
who's your favorite Curry nonbox athlete
of all time oh of all time non boxing oh
man that gotta be oh wait you said non
basketball it's either between Cristiano
Ronaldo or Steph Curry or Tiger Wood I
got a lot actually tiger those three
those three very interesting so you said
Renaldo tiger and uh Steph Curry Steph
Curry okay what do you like about those
three I love tiger with tenacity and and
his professionalism and how he holds
himself um I like that he took a big
heat for what he did outside of his
sport and then came back and won the
Masters I loved his relationship with
his son and I love his focus and not
just just like his his the way he
carries himself within the cameras like
he just he just acts like they're not
there like I love it um Ronaldo I love
his dedication to his body and just
being perfect you know your body is your
temple and I feel like he represents
that really well Steph Curry because of
his faith and because of his um he he
was a he was the one he was small but
then he made something out of himself
because he you know he he followed he
reached himself to his fullest potential
because they counted him out because he
was so small I also like Tom Brady even
though Tom Brady you unfollowed me why
did you unfollow me that's messed up Tom
Brady followed you and unfollow yeah I
don't know why no I think you know what
I think it is it's because we were going
to go to lunch he invited me to lunch
and somehow I just couldn't make it I
kind of blew it off and then and he was
just that makes sense for him to un
follow makes sense seven Championship
can we can we look it I'm sorry let's
rekindle it we hang out oh man so okay
go back to that
so I got a I got a very direct question
for you I wouldn't unfollow nobody for
that though you wouldn't have unfollowed
anybody that because because I
understand life life happens but it's
Tom Brady bro that's true Tom Brady so
you to me that's true that's true yeah
to me you got to respect that you got to
respect yeah I think one of the things I
I I I learned a long time ago but I was
younger though I was younger then oh
great then by the way he's going to see
this and he's going to be like okay cool
I wouldn't be surprised if we get a
following the next week when he sees
this Tom cuz
that's hey Patrick Mahomes follows me we
love each other Patrick Mahomes you
excited about those guys winning this
year like Super Bowl going to be about
hanging out with Patrick and Kelsey for
a minute I love them they're such good
energy um Patrick's mom is cool Randy
she's dope she believes in God we always
have conversations about God I think me
that's funny I I think I talked to Randy
mom more than I do Patrick really yeah
yeah we're always we're always talking
about
God she's cool she's real she there's
something about P there's something
about Patrick I like a lot if anybody's
going to beat Tom Brady's record it's
Patrick Mahomes there's no other guy
psycho competitor I like but listen I'm
a I'm a Tom guy I'm a diard Tom guy I
think Tom's a Tom got that tenacity too
he's got so so question I want to bring
back to you so you said tiger you said
Steph you said Ronaldo right okay so
here's question for you and I always I
message Ronaldo too all the time I tell
him bro how do you get your body like
that that's crazy have you seen the
interview when uh they're asking about
his son how bad his son wants it you
ever seen that clip uhuh so there's a
clip uh uh Rob if you can find this clip
Ronaldo asked about his son okay can you
find Ronaldo asked about his son and you
have to see what he says just put
Ronaldo asked about his son just put
Ronaldo asked about his son look what I
asked him I said happy Easter to you and
your Amia I said what I tell hey Ronaldo
if you don't buy can you tell me your
diet
regimen that's not the one there's a
clip where he's asking him about they're
asking him about his son I'll find a
clip I'll send it to you but I want to
stay here with you okay here's a
question I want to ask
you so for me um I had a vision and my
vision was 20 years and there were two
guys in the industry I respected a lot I
admire a lot both of their pictures are
on my vision board where I said I want
to be able to do what these guys did
except I want to do it at a younger age
and it was a number I wanted to be able
to build an insurance company to a point
and get a number that to me was a real
number after 20 years I wanted to sell
for quarter of a billion dollars and I
wanted to get that check so 20 years I I
was obsessed the level of focus that
just doesn't make any sense right I'm
doing 100 a week I'm running 6 months on
the road traveling left and right and
I'm married I I got four kids now and
I'm creating content I'm doing this I'm
building an insurance company we got
50,000 agents Nationwide all this stuff
is going on at the same time right and
my biggest fear was the following and I
want to see within the space because
whatever I touch that I'm going to run I
want to compete with the best of the
best I don't want to be one of the I'd
like to compete for the top spot and if
I don't get it I'm okay with that not
that I'm okay with that I'm okay with it
if I give everything I got but God
forbid I don't it's going to it's going
to it's going to mess with me so I don't
want to go through it so for you do you
think you're giving everything you got
to the game yes let the Lord's will be
done not mine but I give everything I'm
a monster do you think you're giving
everything I think I'm get everything
right and here's what I mean by that you
want to know why tell me because nobody
could do what I do 7 in the morning I
wake up I could wake up earlier I've ran
with Floyd at 3: in the morning but I'll
tell you my regiment I wake up around in
training camp 7:25 um a.m. of course and
I shadow box for 15 rounds now so 15
rounds straight at shadow box before I
have anything in my system I don't drink
water I do anything I do that and then I
do band work obviously I start off with
band work first to tow my muscle up and
then I do meditations and then I go into
uh then I go into uh Shadow Boxing 15
rounds and then I do my ab circuit which
is nuts you know it's it's crazy you
know and then after that boom shower
boom boom boom then I get a little bit
of beet juice I get whatever food I need
boom boom boom at 12:00 I head to the
gym I go from the gym from 12: to 1:30
to 2:30 it's around that range then
after that I rest up I go on a probably
an hour walk of just meditations
non-stop I'll show you all my notes a
Non-Stop so I just let wisdom flow
through me about the day and how I'm
feeling and what I've learned about it
so this is just a glimpse of my notes
these are daily notes mhm you know so I
go into meditations I start off with
marus aelius meditations and I just let
him talk I don't even really listen to
him
cuz you know it's not all wisdom comes
from God so that's what I say to myself
anyways he starts talking boom boom boom
then my train of thought starts going
and then I let God lead me to whatever I
need to you know listen to read and then
I just start
writing non-stop then I come back I play
a little bit ping pong with my Coach Bo
boom boom I kill him Si's gonna get mad
because he think he beat me um anyways
then after that I go to strength and
condition around I believe 7:00 around
that time from 700 to like 9:30 cuz me
and Si train hard so we go boom then
after that I go run five miles with a
Sonos suit on then I come back eat and I
go to sleep and do it again the next day
what what what goal I mean if you could
do that brother you got it well but but
here's here's what I would tell you I
would say uh uh couple things for you to
consider because you're you're in your
world and you got to do what you got to
do I don't know your world but what what
goat what goat do you talk to that you
allow to kick your ass not within got
boxing space any goat Tomy like I don't
want to hear what you don't want to hear
for
example um I'll let my coach Dereck
James tell me what I don't want to hear
no it's not what I'm talking about CU
Derrick James is not a goat okay and I
don't know Derek James to be honest with
you and I'm not saying anything negative
or positive I don't know the guy but if
he was a goat I'd know he's a goat so
he's not in the Goat Mountain what I
mean by goat is the follow I'm talking
greatest of all time so you know guy
right now text me I know who this guy is
I'm not even going to Define who this
guy is because the Market's going to
know who I'm talking about he is a guy
that's within my space that wants to do
something that I've done and I think
he's capable of doing it very capable of
doing it okay and maybe even bigger I
believe he's capable of doing it but I
know if he's full of [__] I know it so
he can't lie to me
you can sit in front of me and give me
your lip service all you want you know
how I know that I've done that as well
all right and I remember when I did it
and a guy that was a goat in my space
put me in my place and I sat there I'm
like oh [__] how do you know all my bad
habits and what I'm doing and what my
Temptations are what my fears are all
this other stuff you know one of my
favorite posters I had uh uh pictures I
had in my uh presentation folder was a
picture of Roger Federer and tiger
Walkin this is in 08 years ago this is
when he was killing everybody this is
pre the accident this is pre all the
girls coming out all that stuff
right and I learned uh even uh I don't
know if you've seen the tiger
documentary The two-part documentary if
you've never seen it highly recommend
you watch it there's a part in the
documentary where Michael says tiger was
safer on me because I understand tiger
he said tiger would come to me and
around me he could be anybody he wants
and it's between me and tiger no body
else knows why though because those are
goats hanging out together tiger you
take away what he did with girls and all
the distractions he had with the the
porn stars whatever it was Tao would
have annihilated Nicholas it's not even
close okay it's they're not even in the
same league respect to person that came
before you Nicholas you got to give that
PR 100% you got to give that but at the
same time his trajectory what this guy
was doing I got the chills all of my
body just thinking about it right well
then it's then I got the answer for you
but but let me finish the question want
to hear your thoughts I want to know
which goat you allow to privately kick
your ass
Floyd okay he could tell me I don't I
don't really speak he's a goat I don't
really speak when Floyd's talking and I
speak a lot I'm a big talker I don't
speak when Floyd's talking got it I just
he tells me a bunch of things I'm like I
just shut up and he Floyd could talk
does he call you out though oh yeah yeah
he's called me out on like straight up
you're full of you know you're full of
it here you're not doing this here is he
like that or what's how's he is he very
gentle giving you the feedback or so so
it's like um what does Jesus say be um
be wise as a serpent gentle as a dove he
comes out of gentle okay he doesn't come
out it like and that works for you cuz I
don't do that and God doesn't do that to
me or is it unless it's bad bad right
unless I'm really messing
up so I could I could I could hear
Floyd's voice and I could respect it and
I really do I don't really talk when he
when he's speaking he even says it like
no one to speak and no one not to speak
like that's facts you know so I really
respect Floyd um more than you a lot of
people you know who who and maybe I
don't even know if you can say this
maybe you could what is one uh uh uh
feedback he gave you where he you know
like has there been the conversation to
say Ryan do you realize you can be one
of the greatest to ever lace him up like
do you realize that and then to to go
and say Here's the three things that
you're doing that's getting in your way
has that conversation taken place with
Floyd or not
yet okay but did he call me Canelo and
javante Davis the three faces of boxing
yes that's not what I'm talking about
though it's not what I'm talking about
so you're talking about a more indepth
real raw conversation I'm talking about
uh uh so I'm I'm in so I talk to a lot
of people that call me and we have
conversations that no one knows about
it's just us and them right Co when the
other day we're driving to Dylan soccer
game and I'm playing the speech that
Shaq gave at Kobe's funeral right at the
Staple Center and then I play him
Michaels and Michael says you know the
the most annoying thing about uh uh uh
Kobe he was like the younger brother
that was the past he would come and take
your clothes he would do this he would
do that he said I'd get text at 3
o'clock in the morning he says one time
Kobe asked me a question he says hey
Michael you know
uh uh uh I'm trying to teach my daughter
footwork and I says okay how old is she
12 years old Kobe says what were you
doing to improve your footwork at 12
years old Michael says at 12 years old I
was playing baseball right but Michael
said the level of obsession Kobe had for
the game of basketball Michael Kobe
helped me get better right Kobe helped
me get better so there's certain people
that know exactly what it takes to be
the greatest of all time that can talk
to you in a way nobody else can talk to
you but it's direct challenging and
calling out right and I understand the
gentle side but I think you know Tom
Brady for instance you know when Tom and
I were talking and having a conversation
about what it is on how you drive your
guys right there's different ways to
drive somebody that's just happy to be
in the NFL okay there's certain guys who
drive that's just man he just wants to
go party have a good time girls all this
stuff and then there's a few of the guys
you drive that's kind of like nah man
this [__] this this guy wants to
be the guy like he wants to walk in the
room and everybody stops cuz he walked
into the room it's a different kind of
respect that person
gets how close are you to other goats
where they talk to you that way because
to me so so I outside of Mayweather I'll
hit you some
yeah the difference between Michael and
Kobe Michael
was just the goat and never gave anybody
the gems he never gave anybody the key
right unless instead of the Last Dance
he he gave a little bit of gems with the
last dance but he wasn't really
transparent and Direct on how he how he
was the goat what was his mindset we
don't really know we just seen that he
was he was that guy Kobe he told you
every step of the way how he did it I
woke up at this time I did this I did
that he broke it down for you he
directly broke it down for you that's
why I respective I cried when Kobe died
I cried my eyes up when Co when Michael
Jackson died and when Kobe died I was
young when Michael died I was like eight
years old but I cried I remember that
and I cried when Kobe died those are the
two people that I actually cried
celebrity wise yeah and and I I looked
up actually if you ask me that question
again I looked up at Kobe heavy always
wanted to you ever read Mamba mentality
I didn't but I but but I've seen so much
things that that Kobe has said can you
text Mario or Sam and see if I got a
mambo mentality just grab a copy even if
it's mine I want to give it to him can
you make sure you do that just we got if
not have somebody go pick it up and
bring it here so I want to give it to
him at dinner if he can do that Rob I I
I watch his documentary amazing I watch
who Kobe so let's go back to Michael on
what you said with Michael right here's
my read on Michael I've never met
Michael I've spent a lot of time with
Kobe but I've never met Michael and with
Michael you know Michael's a pre social
media era right so that's a different
era number two Michael and Kobe
Michael's posting up on Kobe and Kobe is
saying hey when you're doing a
turnaround what's the weight you know on
the leg when you're feeling the guy
behind you what he do and Michael's
giving him feedback but but do you know
what was the level of obsession that
Michael respected about Kobe nobody was
curious about information and wanting to
learn more than Kobe it's almost
annoying
Kobe Bryant's personality is almost
annoying because it's kind of like dude
can you like relax relax bro like Let It
Go who enjoy yourself for second no man
I'm not going to let it go I'm I'm I'm
my number is 24 one more than 23 right
I'm I'm Kobe right I'm 24 you're 23 I'm
24 I love that his number was eight too
the first one whole different reason
then then he changes it when Colorado
all this stuff then he becomes black
mamba you guys think I'm this guy you
want to paint me as a bad guy no problem
I'll be exactly what you want me to be
I'll be this
K everybody right and he came for
everyone's throat look at how many
reviews this book's got 28,000 260 wow
you know I I think you know when I when
I watch
you and I spend time with you I'm in the
business of body language I'm in The Bu
I've set with Mobsters I've set with
gangsters I've set with politicians I've
set with billionaires I've set with
athletes I've set with goats I've sat
with criminals I've sat with a lot of
different people okay and you know
maybe because in the last 25 years I've
recruited I don't know how many hundreds
of thousands of people to the insurance
industry and I've licensed 50,000 of
them so I've done a lot of this this is
my specialty oneon-one in a room just
talking to the person and purely trying
to find the best to pull out of this
person to somehow get him to see
something maybe they didn't see before
right when I when I watch
you
um and you know I
see see a few things I call my La guys
and I said guys so help me understand
you know because I'm not in the boxing
space but I'm in the fan space I'm a fan
right and I watch you fight I'm a fan
this guy's freaking exciting you know
it's fun to watch what's going to happen
with this dude this is like could this
guy and Davis and Canelo some of these
guys bring that excitement back to
boxing I'm having dinner last week with
Dana and we're talking about what
happened to boxing he knew many years
ago boxing was going to lose it because
of whatever like look what Dana did to
UFC right and watch what's going on with
boxing now and all this stuff so boxing
needs some guys like you right but if I
maybe direct with you Ryan you could
always be direct I I don't know if
you've you you can fully disagree and
and tell me Pat I don't agree with you
at all I don't know if you have fully
committed
to Mamba mentality Brady mentality Messi
mentality Mayweather mentality right I
don't know if you fully committed to
that yet
so it prompts me to think a couple
reasons why let's let's go through the
why right okay so one would be
uh you you are you are a very very
goodlook guy okay you know and the way
you see that with girls right it's like
oh my God Ryan Garcia is coming to my
they're losing their minds right okay
guess what if you ain't good-looking you
are never going to know what that's
going to feel like so let's set that
part aside anybody can criticize it you
can't do that but you know who knows a
lot about that Michael Michael was very
goodlook all right so was Kobe um so is
Tom Brady good-look guy he dated all the
models and all this stuff and all these
things that goes with it okay so that
can't be used as an excuse next the next
thing is who's in your ear I've worked
with certain guys where one of the guys
I worked with where it was a trend he
could never trust anybody ever he
couldn't trust anybody and first like
you know for example like some of the
guys I called they they're like Pat you
know he's training with Canelo it
doesn't work he goes with G and doesn't
work now it's Derrick James not going to
so hey he was first with this and now
it's you know Golden Boy and maybe it's
going to be Mayweather this this this
this that it doesn't work and why this
and why that maybe there's an ego issue
with this no problem great that's what
La folks may say you're an LA guy I'm an
LA guy fine people can have their
opinions when they're saying that
great so girls maybe somebody is in your
ear like uh
I have two people in Dallas one time
every time we would have issues in a
company when I went to these two guys no
matter who it was they always defended
me and they they even increased my
temper about whoever I was asking them
about for example imagine I'm like Ryan
you won't believe what Rob did today d d
you would say what did Rob say you know
what I would do for you you got a fire
Rob and then eventually I'm like dude
you know what I'm not coming to talk to
you so so I sat to these guys down one
time they know cuz we had this
conversation last week and I said hey
moving forward you guys have to be
equalized by these other two people that
I want to bring in when I bring these
two guys and these two people in and I
would say so what do you guys think
about what Rob did these guys would say
what I can't believe what Rob did we got
a fire these gu would
say yeah uh Rob respectfully I disagree
with you because I think we have to
understand what's going on there and and
here what I think happened with Rob and
Pap and I'm in the middle I'm like oh
[__] never thought about this and then
the other guy would say yeah and I don't
know if I agree with him but I would
give I I definitely don't agree with uh
you guys that say this about Rob because
I think let's not forget what happened
to Rob three years ago and D so it's
either girls it's either you
know lack of coachability it's either
somebody's in your ear right that's
causing you to always run or last but
not least it's the fear of success
because the fear of success is a real
thing the fear of success like uh uh you
know you you know you can compete with
everybody at the highest level you know
that nobody needs to tell you that I
don't think you need any of that I think
you know that
yourself but you know am I am I willing
to get freaking maniacally obsessed like
a Kobe like a Michael like a Brady like
a Messi like a Canelo like a Mayweather
like these guys I don't know at the end
of the day yeah you'll never know
because I what I ask what I ask
everybody yeah find out if you hang out
with me for a week straight yep then
you'll know respectfully you'll never
know because you're not in my circle you
you're asking me yes you you'll never
and I'm not saying I'm not I totally
understand what you're saying I'm not
trying to offend you no no not at all I
fully understand what you're saying at
the end of the day you don't know the
extents I go to training you don't know
how much I train you don't know how much
I do all you can see is from outside
perspective and that's how everybody
could see me but at the end of the day I
know for a fact I truly believe this
nobody in boxing Works harder than me
and I know oh he's so he's everywhere
because they don't know I could train at
anytime I don't really I I don't sleep I
don't that 3 and o'clock morning morning
run with Floyd that was my idea Floyd
let's go let's hit this run oh wow you
know what Floyd told me on the run and I
promise you this God is my witness he
looks at me in eye and he almost sounds
like he's crying I never see him act
like I I don't you only hear his voice
get like this very few times he goes I
respect you just like that I respect you
like with like like like you know when
Tyson is Holy yeah I respect you and I
was like why Floyd and I'm getting the
chills all over my body because nobody's
doing what you're doing nobody me Floyd
calls me all the time I'm running all
the time every time Floyd calls me I'm
running Floyd's like I'm so proud of you
I'm proud of you I'm proud of you I'm
proud I just know it if you just spend
some time with me you're you're going to
say this kid is different you're going
to say he is different and you're going
to say I have no worries on whoever he
fights you're going to say that just
spend a week with me that's all I say
let's go hang out let's do what we do
you're going to see something and I'm
not here to prove myself to nobody at
the end of the day no bro I'm a fan I'm
not give me give me five months yeah so
when I make over 100 million uh dollars
this year and I go beat these guys yeah
then we come back and we talk again
that's all we have to do I'd love to
yeah that's all we have to do yeah cuz I
know what I'm projected to make I know
how much money I'm going to make I know
I have my whole business I have
everything in order at the end of the
day I already have things in place where
I'm good now all I can do is focus on
boxing and and focus on every move I
have to make make you know I've got to
be here I got to be here but I know I
have everything in place I have
everything in order at this current now
granted have sometimes I've been like
Lot's wife and looking back and then I
end up being salty because oh should I
bring this person back on or should I
bring that person should I listen to
that person and then when I do listen
then I'm back in the same position have
I done that before yes have I made the
same mistake repetitive times
yes but do I have a different outlook on
on how I need to move forward now yes
because at the end of the day sometimes
it takes for me I'm stubborn sometimes I
need to I need to fall down multiple I
need to scratched my knee a couple times
ah that hurt maybe I just didn't do it
right last time and then I hurt my KNE
knee again okay ah D I really did I'm
done doing that I'm done doing all right
God I got you I'm done I relate to that
I can see that no I'm I'm only asking a
question
because um you you know when uh uh uh
you make 30 grand a year and you met
your first person that makes $100,000
year do you remember the first guy you
met that makes 100 Grand a year okay I
never met that guy like I was like dude
I can't believe that that guy makes
100,000 I'll never forget it was one of
our relatives we were in Granada Hills
and they said this lady is a professor
she makes $50 an hour this is 1993 1994
I was like what does she make MH and you
have no idea how different I looked at
this lady we were in granad hill at this
lady house Rosa and I say yeah she makes
$50 $50 an hour like damn holy [__]
couldn't believe it
right and then we went to a house my
uncle's house who lived next to Snoop
and it was a first million doll home I'm
like oh my God this is a freak tennis
court basketball court 7200 square ft
culdesac freaking Birds massive 30ft
Nest damn jacuzzi in a living bedroom
office in the house wow 19 93 94 crazy
never seen a million dollar home right
and they make 100 Grand a year in the
industry and you're like oh come all
right I'm make 100 Grand let me tell you
what's going and he going you make you
make how much a million year damn I'm a
little guy hey I'll make 2.8 million oh
that guy made 10.8 oh [__] I'm a little
guy oh you make $5 million that guy
makes 120 damn little guy $250 million
you ain't out with billiones hey what's
up guys hey how you doing you're like
you feel it's always like this one thing
on the competitive side right now listen
I'm not telling you turn them into a God
but what I'm saying is as a competitor
you always got to strive to get to the
next whatever may be for you right okay
so I think I think for you a guy that's
a celebrity you're famous you're young
you're a rising star you're 25 freaking
years old if if I'm writing a plan with
you and I'm looking at you as my younger
brother okay and I would sit there and
do a business plan with you I would say
dude Ryan here's what I would do for you
go have dinner with Michael ask go have
dinner with Messi you know where Messi
lives right next door to my house
tonight when we have dinner I'll show
you his House's right next door go knock
on his door he's probably going to be
open if tonight we go to his door you're
at the door he's probably going to have
a conversation with you right if we go
to
Messi um go to Federer right make a list
of Goat Mountain and go to all them
privately don't tell anybody it's your
project for you no one needs to know
don't post a picture about it don't
publicize it and then two years later
when you get paid a court of a billion
dollars and then tell everybody let me
tell you guys what I did last two years
here's what I did and asked them can I
ask you a question Tommy what's that can
I ask you a question Messi what's that
tell me what I I want to know what it
takes to be on the Goat Mountain what's
the difference in mentality and you know
how you're taking notes while you're
walking and you're reading one of the
most important books in the world
meditations insane yeah marus yeah so
you you're it's going to stick with you
you're going to be like damn you know
damn so and and the main question is the
following what is the difference with
being one of the best of all time versus
what is the difference between being a
goat and then watch what they tell you
and then when they tell you and you buy
yourself in the car and there's nobody
else there it's the most important thing
you're on a flight you're in an Uber
you're in a car you're with the limo
guys driving you you got music playing
you're walking in the morning you're
walking out your 1:30 when you go for
your 1 hour walk that you do and you say
Ryan what do you want to do where do you
want to go with this what's next for you
you what are we doing what are we doing
bro because you know who's the only
person that's been in your life for
every second of your life God and you
only person no one else the journey is
with the man upstairs and the journey is
with you yeah only you know your fears
your inner inse we're never going to
know it you know it I know my inner
fears and insecurities I know mine I
like sharing it person I totally get it
me too because in a way people need to
see that you're human you're not
Untouchable but I think you're at a very
pivotal phase of your
life uh because you got a you got a 10
to a 13 year
run
where where you can really you know
really do some damage 10 to 13 year and
by the way with Mayweather saying to you
you know when I look at you I see this
this this and that you know he needs to
say that meaning he's a businessman he
knows what he's doing he ain't dumb
either maywether is a very very wise guy
of course maywether to me you know if
you've ever read the book 33 strategies
of war or 40 Laws of Power Mayweather is
a very very brilliant guy by the way I
got this book ordered for you I'll give
it to you tonight when we get to the
house the Mambo one the Mamba one yeah
Mayweather's a very the 33 Strategies of
War you don't need to read this just
read the listen to the audio book bro
just that's the one oh bro look you're
going to listen to this and for sure 40
Laws of Power by Robert Green one I love
the 33 number yeah I like that yeah I
mean when you go through some of this
stuff you you know like like remember
when Connor came back and he lost one of
the
fights uh this is pre the phase that he
went through where now he's like a he's
like a full-blown actor celebrity all
this
stuff he spent a lot of time with Tony
Robbins okay very a lot of time with
Tony Robbins and one of the fights when
he came Tony was in his
corner and one of the games one of the
fights he lost he said I feel bad he
said why do you feel bad he says because
all the thousands of hours coaches have
spent with me I've let him down he is
I'm not worried about the money I'm
already financially free I'm already
wealthy all this stuff I feel bad the
fact that these guys really were there
training and I was five minutes late I
would be a little bit casual with this I
was a little bit this says I'm not happy
about that I lost this game my coaches
were there for me I messed it up it was
one of the most noble moments I ever saw
with Connor it was such a beautiful
moment when I saw that
um I really enjoy company yeah yeah and
and and again going back with you look
we've spent uh uh we've talked a few
times we've spent a few hours together
whether it was at that event or here now
having this convers I'm really enjoying
talking to you by the way I like we're
going through this but I would be
curious to know what you do next I'm so
curious Ryan I'm so curious to know what
you do next because I think your
upside could be Monumental I think your
upside could be a way for you to make a
lot of wealth
be a great father Yes be a great
performer be a great Son of God y
represent boxing the right way represent
your heritage the right way Mexican
Community very very proud people very
54% of our company is Hispanic the
insurance company and they're very proud
we got them from meakan halisco sakas
Wan we got him from uh waka you name him
Durango we got him from you know all
over the place right there's a lot of
Pride there um a lot of Pride there U
you ever watched the movie count of mon
Christo my dad has he been trying to
make me watch that' be good for you bro
count of m c yeah it' be good for you it
it'd be good for you it'd be good for
you anyway so I love movies by the way
you do and I love music what's your
favorite movie my favorite movie um is
Lion King um Lion King Lion King yeah
but but my second favorite is uh in
Stellar then you got setion and then you
got Moneyball and then you got Moneyball
moneyball's great why you like Moneyball
Moneyball is just interest concept of
numbers gu try to go
against you know what people's instincts
are interesting yeah Money Ball was cool
um what was that one movie um Slum Dog
Millionaire that was great um there's a
lot of great movies out there was was
wait there was one that I was going to
say what movie was
that it's slipp be my mind right now
there's another oh Gladiator there it is
Gladiator was amazing gladiator's top
five for me uh who's your top five
boxers of all
time who would you put as your top five
you talking impact you talking of a just
straight sport I mean what are you
talking about if you were to say the
greatest top five greatest boxers of all
time who would you put on that
list I would
put I
think it's for me personally oh my gosh
it's like Sugar Ray Robinson Floyd
weather and sugaray Leonard those are
and Roy Jones Jr those
four I can put them in your interesting
list yes really huh do you know who uh
uh he was cold you know the moment when
I knocked this guy out with one punch
his name was Franc Francisco fona look
look that up real quick and let's pull
that video so I knock him out cod with
the left hook my friend posted up a
video of sugar a Robinson it's called
the perfect left hook
and then I said I'm going do that right
now moments before my fight I'm praying
the locker room God saying he's going to
be knocked out Cod start praying for I
said okay check this
out this literally you cannot make this
up and you can look at all my post how
long ago is this how long ago this is
right before Co okay so this 2019 2020
oh it is 2020 got it barely 2020
February
14th it's literally 3 months before Co
before it all went
crazy Rob go back I think it's that
Spike so go back a little bit right
there
yeah right
here of course now check out sugaray
Robinson's left hook and tell you now
you tell me which one is the more
perfect left
hook I'm just saying sugaray Robinson
perfect left hook now you tell me who's
the the better left to I got to say me
if I'm being real I got to say me which
one is it is there one that you want to
play no no no perfect punch is the
perfect punch right there perfect
punch they say this was the perfect
punch boom he hits him with a body shot
catches in between the punch damn I
think mine's way better go back again
let's see one more time rob you better
start saying Ryan Garcia a perfect
punch wow that's nice though I give him
it but my guy didn't even move my guy
did not move wow and I caught him in now
go to the slow-mo version of Ryan Garcia
versus vona now look at this this is
crazy and and during this
time just go to it and just lower it to
yeah let it get close to it let it get
close to it before you do it even closer
it's in the one minute
range let it go a little bit more WAP
before we see what happens to it yeah go
let it go it's coming it's coming it's
coming it's let's go and then I'm going
explain to you what I felt in that
moment and this is the
truth you got to you got to turn before
he gets there it's about to come up it's
coming it's coming don't worry Bo I
already knew I had to so dvon knocked
him in round there was a glancing left
hook didn't look like much but those are
the shots right there put 25 now watch
this you can turn off the audio so we
can see it yeah there you go look at
this it goes to closeup
boom right when he
threw wow that's perfect I caught him in
between a punch within a punch on top of
it when I was fighting him
yeah I was so F I was in such a flow
Zone mhm that the moment I looked at him
I could see his chin I was consciously
there and I said his chin is open it
felt like I had all the Time in the
World to hit him with that shot but if
if you watch it in fast motion happened
like that but in my point of view I had
all the Time in the World to hit him it
was like you know when you you key up
the ball and you could just hit it
whatever you want it felt just like that
H how was it fighting javante Davis what
was he like and for the first time ever
in the back room I said to myself I'm
losing this fight oh you said you knew
mhm I knew right in the back room
nothing's going right I'm so weak none
of my punches are coming off sharp I'm
going to lose this fight I just said how
I'm going to lose this fight this going
to be crazy who' you say that to just
for yourself got him how am I going to
lose okay all right trust you God so
I'll tell you a story about this
so Justin Bieber and Bad Bunny are
supposed to walk me out both of them
fall out God why why are they what is
going
on God says CU I want you to walk out
with
me and only me I said what do you mean
by
that I opened up Tik Tok comes out the
song Oceans I said I know exactly okay
okay I'm coming out to that song I made
that decision within the fight week that
wasn't something I pre-planned I said
Okay God I hear you I tell them to play
what part and all that Bo boom I break
it down I hit the numbers boom boom boom
they got it all on set and I say to
myself God I trust that's what song's
about Trust You Without Borders you know
take me to deep Waters and I'm going to
trust you I knew I was going to lose but
it's okay I'm going to trust you I'm
going give him my all right now so the
moment I caught him in the second round
I try to knock him out
I said I'm so weak I got to try I got to
try to end it early I never seen a
person have the most saddest face I ever
seen in my life when I looked at javante
he looked like he's so sad like like he
had genuine fear in his mind that
something's going to bad is going to
happen him if you go to the beginning of
that second round I cracked him and then
he was like he literally stopped and
looked at me and
goes grabs me and I'm trying to kill him
because I'm like I have no power but I'm
going to just use whatever I have right
now
he recovers then drops me I'm thinking
he's going to come after me I said let's
go he starts moving the same way he was
he told me if I ever drop you like Luke
Campbell dropped you I'm gonna go get
I'm gonna go get your ass I said okay he
dropped me what happened I got right
back up and I said let's go he started
retreating how do you Retreat when you
just drop somebody that's already
weakened I'm already weaken why don't
you just come and destroy
me you already dropped me because he
knew what I was really
about it's okay at the end of the day I
told everybody I'm going to do this this
and that I'm going get everything back
in blood I will never let nobody play me
like that in negotiations ever again
that will never happen
ever I'm going to beat this guy this guy
this guy I'm going get so big that
javante has to fight me and we're going
to do it on the right and fair terms
this is how fair I am although I'm going
to be bigger than them which I
am I'm going to be a fair Fair honest
man in the new negotiations and we're
going to do it right and I'm going to
beat him and we're going to Sol solidify
that and it's going to be all good
that's what's going to happen mark my
words and we're going to do it the right
weight on the right terms and fair you
and him yeah even though he did me dirty
and they did all these tricks I'm going
do everything fair and from not a
rehydration clause next go around I'm
not going to make him go crazy up and
waight but we could do it at 140 or 147
whatever he wants
and then we're going to do it fair no
rehydration Clause you don't have to do
this you don't have to do that we do
drug testing we do all that but you're
never going to play me again fool me
once shame on me fool me twice shame on
you fool me three times [__] the peace
sign I'm going let the chopper rain on
you I'm coming back for everything I'm
coming back in
blood every when Jesus comes back he's
coming back with blood on his robe from
the enemies he I'm coming back like that
so now you know how I'm coming back I'm
not [__] around I'm really like that
they're going to [__] around and find
out you know the meme the little old man
like [__] around find out that's me
right now [__] around and find
out I listen I think I'd love to see
that fight on the right and guess who
bring up the Conor McGregor Ryan Garcia
uh little thing in the back room look
what Conor says to me go to my Instagram
you go to Instagram right there it's
right
there first look at what he says just
listen to what he's saying yeah I
remember this the
buddy he's one and0 on you us are the
two biggest names in the division I want
to see it again I want to see it again
now and I want to see no
[Applause]
dehydration but you cra to you with the
lead hook hey all the respect the world
you you're a future future is game
watching all the way all the best little
people little do people know
[Applause]
a little bit after well not a little bit
after kind of a long time after this me
now me and Connor are business partners
in a
company it's called monkey tilt shout
out monkey tilt monkey's gonna love that
I said that yeah what's about it's
online uh gaming uh site so me and him
are partners he he is a I don't know if
there's many promoters better than him
in the world fact I don't know if
there's many guys better than him in the
world when it comes out very few right I
don't even know if I if I if I can think
of one who would you put maybe
Mayweather no you looking at yourself
wait confidence no no confence it's the
truth listen but it starts that you're
declaring your intentions and I love it
bring it on love let who can bring the
company up big you want a side wager
I'll get my I'll get my percentage up if
you give your percentage love it
whatever you want and then if you [__]
around and start fighting we do boxing
match though so what's the story with
you doing Jiu-Jitsu you just started
December 2022 were you just having fun
with it or they invited me to do a video
so I just try one of the Gracies right
was it Ren or who was it one of the
Gracies yeah it's one of the family
members but um yeah that was cool thing
is I'm a natural wrestler I'm not so
much
jiujitsu I could no body control I know
I know like like I know where you should
go with your body yeah at the right time
it's called feel I got a good feel I got
a good sense if I do MMA I'mma surprise
everybody I didn't really like this
though I don't like a man on top of me
like that I'm not kid little
uncomfortable I'm like yo this Jiu-Jitsu
is
crazy hey I love everybody though you
know that U yeah no the jiujitsu was
crazy Ryan favorite uh uh top five
favorite Mexican fighters of all time
boxers of all time Mexican yeah
specifically Mexican damn bro cuz you
know who Roy Jones says is the greatest
Mexican boxer of all time and Saul canel
Alvarez um oh I know what happened jio
says are TR no no you you know what him
and he's the best Canelo is the best
Mexican fighter of all time I don't care
what nobody says you can't convince me
otherwise Canelo is the greatest Mexican
boxer of all time the greatest Mexican
fighter of all time stop playing with
him and he's in the conversation to be
one of the best just fighters in general
of all time really you're you're yes he
needs to be he needs to be um Ben aidz
to really solidify it
but this dude's cold and he's obsessed
tell him let's play golf though I need
to see you on that golf course he looks
like he he knows what he's doing by the
way you know who you know who Roy Jones
and Mike Tyson said is the greatest
Mexican boxer of all time who Salvador
Sanchez what Salvador Mexican check that
yeah they said the greatest you know
what age he died at yeah he was young he
died in a car accident he died 23 years
old yeah no he was cold actually I was
going to say Salvador but I didn't I
didn't quite know if he was um Mexican
Mexican but it okay it's unfortunate
that he died young but you can't say
he's the best he died too early to see
the full Cal yeah that's like when Ricky
valin died too early you can't say he's
the greatest you know artist of all you
can't like it's unfortunate it's really
sad but at the end of the day you put
Canelo at the top I think Canelo is the
best fighter um me for Mexico of all
time then it's two Chavis then you go to
Oscar yeah I guess Chavez
Oscar and then me how come you put
fourth I'm going to be the number one
I'm sorry canel I love you I know you're
going to be mad at that let's play golf
first so once I beat you in
golf yeah I'm I'm going mess around and
beat all your
records oh man there's some there's
something attractive about Canelo
there's very um he's very Noble that's
what attractive him he's a man you know
he's the epitome of a man you know what
I mean like he holds himself like a man
like he doesn't mess around like some
people say misogynistic but it's not
really misogynistic it's more like I'm a
man and and you better calm the [__]
down right I'm the man I'm that guy when
he walks I'm that guy respect me if you
don't respect me I'm out you his eyes
tell a million stories look at those
eyes I just love the freaking fire in
those eyes right I do too I I I like I
like his personality don't get me wrong
I just I'm a different
person I'm I'm like that when I have to
be like like that he's like that all the
time that's the difference he's like
that all the time I'm only like that
when if [__] hits a fan you going then
run I tell people just run away it's not
worth it just go so so here's what I got
from the conversation today Ryan which
which I'm excited about the followup
okay number one you see how I didn't p
on my watch at all yeah I saw that cuz I
know if you want it you
got you see I you see haven't touch that
watch that could be we could be on the
same
time uh but by the way what was the oh
match good though how was it like shout
out Georgio armman yes of course how was
it like doing a commercial Gator
commercial with Damian Lillard what was
that that was awesome that was awesome
Lillard's a beast me and Lillard had
good uh chemistry like he was one of the
few people that I work with that I
actually like working with he seems like
a standup guy standup solid guy and he
loves boxing is he does
he I I think I need to mention this can
I mention something course if people
hear me making little noises under the
mic is because I personally speak in
tongues it's a gift from the holy spirit
so when you hear me making little noise
don't think I'm tripping is what I'm
saying and don't feel
uncomfortable Dion Sanders did that on
reality TV have you ever met Dion no but
I know everybody around him we were
supposed to meet a couple times but we
just never got to it oh I'm sure you'll
be meeting Dion very soon Dion to me I
think Dion would actually be very good
for you yes I think Dion would be a very
good Mentor for you yes great
conversations to have with him
um okay so here's here's a recap this is
what I took away from today's
conversation learned a lot uh one I
think April 20th is a big day okay Devon
Haney it's going to be a big fight can't
wait for it I think it's going to be
sick I'm looking forward to it now I
know it's not been announced yet I know
in about 3 days it'll be announced
whatever but D now you
prophesizing now youh I'm speaking in
Tong April 2 you know hey you know what
they say in the Bible though they say
it's better that you prophesy than you
speak in tongues I'm with it okay so
that's now you prophesy you say in three
days if it happens in three days we know
you you
say number two for those of you that
were on your way to Vegas rob you to to
bet a million dollars on him staying
with golden for 5 years don't do it yet
hang tight that's two three I can't wait
to hand you Mama mentality book and a
couple other things for you to go
through and also reading the account mon
Cristo which is a great recommendation
your pops has been giving you you ought
to listen to them and the last but Al I
can't wait for you to get your nine
figures and come back and have the
follow-up conversation man I can't wait
for that this has been a blast it's
great having you on brother gang take
care yes and uh April 20th coming soon
take care everybody byee sha I just K it
y chill
out